my name is max shulocker and i'll be
talking about carbon nanotube-based
technologies today
um and i so in my phd here at stanford
i've really focused on
cnts uh but i want to really uh
emphasize some of the broader motivation
behind this work which is uh
transforming
new noun devices and now technologies
such as carbon nanotubes
which are really just of scientific
interest
into actual working useful nano systems
so as a brief introduction
if we look at the last i don't know 10
20 years of electronics as any
indication
of what to expect for the next 20 years
as there is certainly
a tremendous amount of potential and
excitement
there is a definitely the potential and
the ideas to continue to revolutionize
electronic systems
especially given the growing prevalence
of big data
applications really range from biology
we're in genomics
uh there's this amazing statistic that
over 15 petabytes of new dna sequences
are generated yearly
really opening the doors to personalized
medication
uh to building smarter cities it's
projected over 50 billion sensors will
be connected to the internet of things
by 2020
and applications keep you know going on
from retail to finance healthcare
government
the applications are endless and while
this
broad range of applications might seem
like they have very little
in common with one another they actually
share a very
important common thread which is their
demand
for increased computational power and
increased energy efficiency
which is quickly exceeding the
capabilities of electronic systems today
so the question is how are we going to
enable these new
exciting applications well historically
uh in the past we had the answer and it
was with device scaling
we all know moore's law as we make
transistors smaller we can fit more in a
chip
but it wasn't really moore's law which
dictated gains and performance
that was denard's scaling i think bob
caldwell one of the chief architects
of the pentium ships at intel really
said it best when he said
that moore's law is what gives us more
transistors
but it's denard scaling which made these
transistors useful
because denard scaling says that as i
make my transistor smaller
i get gains in performance and the
problem
is that while we might be able to
continue moore's law in the foreseeable
future
to let's say 14 or 10 or seven or even
five nanometer technology nodes
the nerd scaling has long been broken
ever since the early 2000s
so even if we can continue scaling
devices
we are now seeing diminishing returns
so if the question is well where's next
i don't know 1000x
in computational power and efficiency
going to come from
uh it's unlikely that scaling alone is
going to get us all the way there
so then what's the solution moving
forward
well there's a device-centric approach
right maybe there's a magic device out
there which will solve all of our
problems
i for one don't believe that's going to
be the case
as i mentioned scaling is still going on
but is giving us diminishing returns
and there's certainly very important
work looking at new types of physics
like tunnel fets
instead of a mosfet which promised to be
energy efficient
but these are really meant for the low
power low performance application space
due to the limited drive currents it
doesn't really compete when you look at
high performance
so if the answer doesn't lie in devices
maybe it lies in architecture
and again i do not believe that
architectural solutions
alone will get us all the way there
there's of course
important work looking at asics and
system on chips or socs
while these can give us significant
benefits in certain applications
they come at a high design cost and also
have limited applicability
because by definition they are
application specific
additionally there's important work
looking at parallelism we've seen the
evolution
from single cores to multi-cores to
manukaurs
and while this certainly gives us
improved processing power
just like device scaling you see
diminishing returns due to this pesky
thing known as amdahl's law
and we're still fundamentally limited by
our thermal and power constraints of
chips
so if the solution isn't in just devices
or just architecture
what do we turn towards well i believe
the solution lies
in nano systems which is when we can
combine the benefits
of using new devices and new nano
technologies with the benefits of new
systems and new architectures
which are inherently enabled by using
these new technologies
i think there are two very important
aspects of nanosystems
uh the first is uh being able to
transform a new device
into a new system as an example carbon
nanotubes
we know they make a pretty good
transistor they have some unique
fabrication
processing they make great sensors for
more and more applications
and the question is well what type of
system or architecture do we want to
build
that really leverages and combines all
these benefits
now the second important aspect of
nanosystems is
but once you think of the system you
want to build you then need to build it
and this is where so many emerging noun
technologies fail
because many if not all emerging noun
technologies
are inherently prone to substantial
imperfections and variations
so while maybe you can build a single
transistor or two transistors
which are high performance building an
entire system
is normally out of the question and oh
by the way it's not just these emerging
nanotechnologies
where variations are a concern as we
scale down traditional silicon cmos
variations are becoming uh increasingly
more of a concern as well
so these to me are the important aspects
of nanosystems
and in today's talk i'll really be
speaking about carbon nanotubes
uh in this broader context of realizing
nanosystems
i'll first discuss how we overcome the
inherent imperfections of cnts
through combined processing and design
tricks
i'll then show that we can for the first
time build actual
systems using carbon nanotubes such as a
basic computer
built entirely from c fats then
lastly i'll talk about how by really
leveraging
all of the benefits of cnts we can build
brand new types of systems and
architectures
such as monolithically integrated
three-dimensional ics
with interleaving stacked layers of
logic and memory logic and memory
which have huge potential for these big
data applications moving forward
so with that let me introduce you all to
carbon nanotubes let's make sure
everyone's on the same page
so a carbon nanotube or a cnt is
essentially just a
rolled up sheet of graphene to form a
nano cylinder with a diameter of
approximately 1.2 nanometers
a carbon nanotube field effect
transistor or c in fat
is formed by using the cnts as the
channel of the transistor
with traditional lithographically
defined source drain and gate regions
here's the sem of acm fat we've
fabricated in our lab
showing the cnts extending through the
channel region beneath the gate
now once we have our c in fats the
natural question is how do you build a
circuit
so i'll show you here's a schematic of a
simple circuit the simplest circuit an
inverter
we have p type c and fets in the pull up
network n type c and fets in the put on
network
and the design follows any traditional
cmos design flow
now i want to highlight that this
inverter looks
picture perfect and that's because we've
drawn in powerpoint
obviously in reality we'll see that
there are many
obstacles towards realizing a working
scene effect technology
uh but before i go into these obstacles
let me give you the motivation
of why we want to use cnfetz for digital
logic vlsi
so the motivation for using cnfetz is
drawn from both experimental and
theoretical work
experimentally it has been shown that c
infest can scale to highly scaled
channel lengths of sub 10 nanometers
and at these highly aggressively scaled
technology nodes have the best drive
currents
compared to compete technologies
additionally c infest can operate at
highly scaled supply voltages
down at 200 300 400 millivolts uh now
beca while maintaining their high drive
currents which is an important point
now because of these device level
benefits we see significant gains at the
system level
it's projected that uh systems built
from c and fets
will achieve over a 10x benefit an order
of magnitude benefit
an energy delay product a metric of
energy efficiency
compared to silicon cmos for large scale
circuits this is done on the entire
power 7 processor
of the model of it so in a world which
cares increasingly more about energy
efficiency
seeing fats not just energy efficiency
but energy efficiency
and computational power combined sea and
fets are a very exciting possibility
but of course as i mentioned despite
this great promise
there are inherent obstacles which have
really prohibited
demonstrating systems using cnts
and two of these inherent imperfections
are mispositioned carbon nanotubes
and metallic carbon nanotubes you'll see
that advanced processing and fabrication
is certainly required to overcome these
obstacles
but you'll also see that processing
alone doesn't get us all the way there
in addition we have to use design and
specifically
imperfection immune design coupled with
these processing techniques
in order to overcome these inherent
imperfections so how do each of these
imperfections
affect our circuits i'll start with
misposition c and t's
here i've drawn a simple circuit and
i'll highlight the misposition c and t
for you you see there's a squiggly one
there and you see in this position
c and t essentially creates erroneous
and random connections in a circuit
causing incorrect logic functionality in
fact here you see the pull up and polar
networks are no longer even
complementary functions of one another
a major no-no for cmos obviously
so that's missed position cnts what
about metallic well a cnt is either
semi-conducting or metallic
due to both the cnt's diameter and its
chirality
a semi-conducting cnt has a band gap of
around
1ev which is perfect for digital logic
while a metallic cnt
has a band gap of around zero and thus
uh it cannot be turned off by the gate
it causes leakage current uh and can
also cause incorrect logic functionality
and thus metallic c and t's are
obviously additional major no-no's for a
circuit
so how do we overcome these two
imperfections well i'll start with
mispositioned carbon nanotubes
and i'll start with a processing
solution the processing solution is
simple
it's well let's just grow the c and t's
highly aligned
and we can do this way for scale to do
so we grow the cnts on a crystalline
quartz substrate
and the cnts grow highly aligned along
the crystalline plane of the quartz
we can achieve very high alignment
roughly nine and a half percent
so in this sem here the horizontal lines
are these catalyst stripes
and these vertical lines are all the c
and t's highly aligned which are running
horizontal on the wafer surface
now while 99 and a half percent might
seem
like a great number right and it makes
sexy sems right i'm seeing some shaking
heads
because of course we know that for vlsi
if we're talking about a billion c and
t's of billing with a b
0.5 percent of a billion is still a big
number so 99.5 percent
doesn't get us all the way there in
addition we have to use design
and we use myth position cnt immune
design i'll go through a concrete
example for you with a
nang gate so we start with our grown
cnts some of them are
mispositioned i've just drawn them
squiggly here i first begin by
depositing the
contact an extended gate and then you
etch out a section of the circuit
now this etch region which is defined
within your standard cell
is absolutely essential as it guarantees
that if there is any misposition c and t
which
could have caused incorrect logic
functionality part of that cnt
must have gone through this etch region
and this would have been removed from
the circuit
now you might be wondering can you just
draw these etch regions for a simple
circle like a nand gate here
and that's not the case you can prove
mathematically this can be applied to
any arbitrary logic function
and what i really want to highlight for
you about misposition c and t immune
design
is that there is no per-unit
customization it
these etch regions are defined with
inner standard cells so you don't
inspect your wafer see where the
misposition cnt is then make your design
no the design works for any arbitrary
wafer that you give me with
wherever the misposition cnts are so
this follows the vlsi design and
processing flow
you can easily imagine in your synopsis
design compiler
you select your c and fet library the
standard cells are
designed using misposition cnt immune
design so you can now synthesize
any logic you want of whatever size
which is guaranteed to be 100
immune to any mispositioned carbon
nanotubes
so now we can overcome this position c
and t's what about metallic carbon
nanotubes
well there is a trivial solution it
simply don't grow any
and while this would certainly work it's
currently unfortunately
impossible and is an open challenge and
might never be possible
so the next best thing we can do is to
remove the metallic cnt's post
growth and for vlsi scale applications
we need to remove over 99.99 of all
metallic cnts
and previous attempts have really been
inadequate
so the technique i'll show you today is
called vmr which stands for vlsi
metallic cnt removal now before i get
into the nitty gritty details of
what vmr is i want to highlight that
just like mispositioned cnt
mean design vmr is universally effective
for all logic designs and also follows
vlsi design and processing flows
so what is vmr well vmr is chip
scale electrical breakdown let me go
through another concrete example for you
here's the scm of a
real growth i've taken and just by
looking at them i can't tell if it's a
semi-conducting or metallic cnt no one
can
so for this example i'll just assign
them at random
the first step of the process is to
deposit
our vmr electrodes now these are
interdigitated electrodes patterned at
my minimum lithographic pitch
and as you'll see part of these vmr
structures become
my final c and phet source and drain
contacts
now once i have this vmr structure on my
wafer i then perform
electrical breakdown on this vmr
structure
to do electrical breakdown we use the
gates of the transistors to turn off the
semiconducting cnts
you then apply a large bias between
these two electrodes
only the metallic c and t's can conduct
current because by virtue of b metallic
they are not turned off by the gate
and if you apply a large enough bias
enough current will flow through the
metallic c and t's that they break down
like a fuse
due to a dual self-heating process you
can actually look under the sem
and see the location of where the
metallic cnts had broken down and been
removed from the circuit we basically
fused them
exactly it was exactly like a fuse exact
same physics technology
so this doesn't leave debris lying
around oh so this is yeah so an
important part about this
is that these vmr electrodes that's a
great question these vmr electrodes are
patterned at the minimum lithographic
pitch
and why is that important because if it
wasn't then the remaining
metallic segment of that cnt it could
still cause incorrect logic
but because it's at the minimum pitch it
cannot cause incorrect logic
that's a very important question so
thanks okay so once we perform
electrical breakdown
on all metallic cnts across the entire
vmr structure which can be across my
entire wafer die
i then etch out the unmuted sections of
the structure and continue with my
regular circuit fabrication
of course following misposition c and t
immune design
now what i've just shown you is a
cartoon of emr
so of course it looks like it works but
the real question is well does it
actually work
and what you're really asking me are two
separate questions
the first is how many metallic c and t's
can you actually remove
and the second question is how selective
are you to not inadvertently removing
the good semi-conducting cnts i want
left in the circuit
right so to determine this we build
arrays of c and fets
each with a single c and t so we inspect
it to make sure it's just one c and t
we measure it to see if it's metallic or
semiconducting then record its breakdown
voltage
and we can build distributions on what a
metallic and when a semiconductor in cnc
will break down
and we can tell this that at
approximately 10 volts or so
we can remove approximately 99.99 of the
metallic cnts
in less than four percent of the
semiconducting cnts now i want to
highlight for you
that this 10 volts is not what you run
your circuit at obviously
this is just a processing step and after
this you then put down your very thin
high
gate dielectric and the metal gate on
top so you can still run your circuit
down at 200 300 400 millivolts no
questions okay
but this shows that vmr and more
generally electrical breakdown
is sufficiently selective for vlsi scale
circuits
how serious is the four percent
semiconductor cnt removal that's great
yeah so i will
i will directly address that later in
this talk
okay and the quest and the the answer is
uh it's an important number
uh which leads into variation how
variations will affect our circuit
so i will definitely talk about that
okay so 9.99 still is a
very low number ah so
if you start with which experimentally
is achieved let's say one percent
metallic in teeth so you start with 99
you period and then you get rid of
another 99.99 you have six ninths
for instance right so it's a
multiplication there right
so and also something important to note
is that you know there are lots of
techniques for sorting
uh sorts such as solution-based sorting
which can get 99.99
or not 99.99 sorry that can get 99
or 99.8 right there's nothing stopping
you from combining techniques
so you can do 99.8 followed by a lighter
vmr like a 99.99
right to get there but for vlsi scale
the spec of
99.99 given a pm of one percent is
sufficient there
so the next question that we always get
for breakdown is does it scale
and i want to show you that in principle
yes it does scale
and we can build c in fats here with
channel lengths ranging from 90
nanometers to 45 nanometers to sub 20
nanometers c in fats
and we can do breakdown on them before
and after here you see the iv curves
you see in all cases we can achieve both
very high on off ratios
and still drive current so it's
selectively removing metallic carbon
nanotubes
so now you might ask me is well you're
just showing me one here right maybe
you're picking and choosing right
but we can actually build circuits so
here's a 32 nanometer circuit
uh using all these techniques and
i actually want to make a quick a quick
aside here
uh which is that the circuit we built
here is actually a sensor interface
circuit
made from c and fence what that means is
that it's a circuit
which converts the value of an analog
sensor like a capacitive sensor
into a digital output for a processor to
read and what i want to highlight here
is that
not only is the circuit made from c and
phets but because the cnts are
inherently very good sensors
the circuit is also the sensor so this
is an integrated sensor interface
circuit and sensor
and i just want to highlight that this
is a really great example in my mind of
some more than more functionality we can
really leverage
by using these new 1d 2d nanomaterials
okay so now that we can overcome these
imperfections we can now start to build
some real systems
and the first subsystem ever built uh
was sasha
which is an admittedly loose acronym uh
for the stanford carbon and
tube-controlled handshaking robot
uh this was demoed live at last year's
isscc and without going into
too many details let me just play a
quick movie
introducing you to sasha
the wafer filled with circuits made from
carbon nanotube transistors
if we zoom in we can see the individual
dies
individual circuits individual
transistors
and the cnts themselves at 100 000 x
magnification we load the wafer into the
probe station
and hook it up to sasha the circuit that
we've built is a capacitive sensor
interface
which is basically a circuit which
converts the value of a capacitive
sensor
into a digital outlet for a processor to
read
hidden in sasha's hand is a switch which
swaps in or out of the circuit a
capacitor
the cnt circuit measures this change in
capacitance by changing its digital
output
the computer averages this output from
the cnt circuit
and based on the output from the cnt
circuit trigger sasha
to shake hands when it is grabbed now
let's watch sasha make some new friends
with no hand on the switch the average
output is low
and sasha doesn't move but when we grab
hands with sasha
the average output jumps up and sasha
shakes our hand
here is sasha in action
all right uh so that was sasha for you
um
so sasha is an admittedly silly
demonstration right i don't view the
future of sea and fats
as being handshaken robots though if it
is you did
see it here first um so
given its slow demonstration sasha does
still show a
very important point which i want to
emphasize for you
which is that c and fets are now
reaching a level of maturity
where we can have live work and
demonstrations of systems
and that is an important takeaway
message so
now that we can build systems we can
really turn our attention towards
building a complete system a basic
computer made from cnts
so let me give you some details about
this computer
it's a single instruction set computer
implementing the subnet instruction
we choose to do this because subnet by
definition is turn complete
which means that given enough memory and
ability to address the memory
it can do any arbitrary computation so
it's very flexible
but here's a schematic of the computer
it has four basic stages
an instruction fetch stage a data fetch
stage an arithmetic unit and a right
backstage
all of which is implemented using cnfs
now here's an sem of the entire computer
to give you an idea of size it's a
couple square millimeters in size
uh though that's almost completely
dominated by probe pads
because we don't package this chip to
sell it of course at least uh not yet
on the computer you can clearly see
where each of these subunits map onto
the sem
you can see the instruction fetch stage
the data fetch the arithmetic block the
right backstage
and to highlight a couple important
numbers for you there are 178 cn fets
totaling tens of thousands of carbon
nanotubes and that is a very
important number because when you start
talking about tens of thousands of
carbon nanotubes
you have to be talking about wafer scale
vlsi compatible now
because you can't start you know tuning
bias voltages here or there
or doing breakdown one at a time you
know so to deal with all the metallic c
and t's we use vmr
to remove all metallic cnts across the
entire computer at once
um and then probably the most important
number
uh to remember is that the computer has
between seven and fifteen stages
of cascaded logic uh and
what the reason why that's so important
is because
the main message behind the computer is
not that
you know oh look here's a basic computer
the main takeaway
is that the cnc computer demonstrates
that you can build
any arbitrary digital logic using cnfs
now that's a powerful statement so i
want to unpack it a little bit
so what does it mean to be able to build
arbitrary digital logic
well you need combinational logic some
notion of computation adders multipliers
right
you also need sequential logic some
notion of time like latches
and you need to be able to cascade so go
combination with a combinational or
sequential to sequential
or combinational sequential combination
or sequential combination sequential you
get the idea
and what the computer shows is that it
has in
every single possible combination of
this really demonstrating that you can
build
any arbitrary digital logic using c in
fact
and that's the major takeaway here yeah
how is it clocked uh we uh
apply an external clock to it um and
their
clock lines running through the yeah
yeah so actually uh if you take a look
at these horizontal horizontal uh lines
here
so these are vdd ground bias rails and
clock rails for instance as well
okay all right and an important thing is
that there's no it's not like oh this
works and this works we'll hook these up
it's one shot the whole thing's done you
measure either works or it doesn't
always for scale all right now given it
is a basic computer we can do what you'd
expect kind of a basic computer to do
so here it's implementing a basic form
of multitasking so it's doing bubble
sort to sort integers and then it's
counting
and it's swapping back and forth between
these completely by itself so it sorts
then it counts then it sorts then it
counts
and it updates a bit in memory uh to
know what it's doing when
and to really demonstrate the
flexibility uh we emulated the
entire nips instruction set on the
computer uh
and commercial instruction to
architecture and uh
the reason we chose mips of course is
because one of its creators
john hennessy is a president of stanford
so it's a nice way for us to pay a
homage to our home institution um
another very important takeaway message
from the computer
is that it's very reproducible these are
80 different arithmetic units
uh measured across a wafer these are 200
latches measured across a wafer
all over laid on top of each other
totaling thousands of cn fets now
and you see that it's a reproducible
process across the wafer
so this is not some picking and choosing
going on another very key takeaway
message for you
okay so now that we can build systems uh
we cannot ignore performance
i and when we look at achieving
performance
there are several obstacles which have
really prohibited achieving high
performance sets in the past
and one of the most substantial
obstacles which has persisted for well
over a decade
is low cnt density drawn here
schematically
by the c and ts being sparse on the
wafer
to achieve that 10x benefit in edp
we actually need much more cnt density
and by the way we need much
much more cnt density so the natural
question for me now
is well how much more density do we need
where do we need to get to where are we
today
so let me show you a typical cnt growth
will achieve between one to five cnts
per micron
the best gross you can have reproducibly
in a lab will be between 10 to 15 cmts
per micron
the world record way for scale cnc
growth can achieve around 25
cnts per micron while the required
density
for high performance c in fats is more
than 100
cnts per micron so you see there's a
significant disconnect
between the required cnt density and the
density which we can
grow in a lab today now while density
itself
is one major obstacle it's actually only
half the problem there's another
obstacle
closely associated with density which is
very often completely overlooked
and this is cnt density variations
let me give you a concrete example this
is the sem
of a growth we've done and you see that
there's non-uniform spacing between the
carbon nanotubes
so if i build a set of c and effects
side by side
i see that each c in fat will be
composed of a different number of cnts
meaning that each transistor will have a
different amount of drive current
now this has significant negative
effects at the system level
causing increased delay variations
decreased noise margin decrease yield
etc so you see that high density is
required
for a high performance c in fat but it's
insufficient
for a high performance system for that
you need to have controlled
cnt spacing variations now to
characterize this non-uniform spacing
in cnts we draw from renewal theory and
statistics
and use this metric called the index of
dispersion for count or idc
which is a very useful metric for
characterizing this non-uniform spacing
distribution
now since i'll be talking about idc i
want to give you some ideas of
some values so you want idc to be as
small as possible
an idc of 0 corresponds to perfectly
uniform cnt spacing
uh this is the per perfect case an idc
of one
would yield a poisson distribution in
the number of c t's and the c
in fact we're fixed with uh and a
typical growth today
including our own we've shown
experimentally is somewhere in between
this around a half
all right so now let me show you the
technique we use to achieve
both high cnt density while controlling
idc
and the technique is called cider an
acronym for controlled idc
density and enhancement by repeated
transfers
the key to cider is a multiple transfer
process
whereby we combine the cnts from
multiple different growth substrates
onto the same target substrate
thereby achieving higher cnt density on
the wafer where we will build our
circuits on
than the density we can grow on any
individual wafer
now i want to highlight that this
transfer process actually has
several very important benefits first
i'll show you later
i can enable some very interesting new
architectures such as monolithically
three-dimensional ics
all right and secondly and this is a
more nuanced point but i think
equally as important i what cider really
does is it also decouple it
relaxes our growth requirements by
decoupling the requirement of idc and
density
i mean right now you need to achieve
both very low idc
and high density both of which
individually are currently
not feasible you combine them it's an
even harder problem
so what cider allows us to do is
decouple this and just focus
on achieving a low idc at a lower
density which we can grow at already
and then use cider to achieve the
density you're saying that it reduces
the variance
no i'm saying it controls it so it stays
constant so
you can do a growth which achieves your
target idc which i'll talk about later
without worrying about density as long
as it's a reasonable density then you
can combine them to achieve the density
okay so what happens if we just try some
naive multiple transfers
well if we do one transfer it works
pretty well both the density and
alignment of the cnts is maintained
so let's just do this multiple times on
top of it on top of it
and we see that by the third transfer we
have disastrous results
there is massive cnt bundling and
aggregation but
clearly we're not going to build high
performance circuits let alone just
circuits out of this
and oh by the way if you even try to do
four transfers
forget about it it wouldn't even stick
to the wafer surface
you can only do a maximum of three
transfers
so now let me show you the cider process
i'll follow by telling you what it can
accomplish
i know this isn't per se a processing
audience but i do want to
kind of show you how you actually do a
transfer because i think it's
pretty interesting so we start with our
cnt's grown on our wafer
and we begin by depositing a thin layer
of gold or copper
we then apply a thermal release tape on
top of this layer of metal
we then prepare our transfer substrate
or our target substrate
and we uh take off this thermal release
tape with gold and embedded cnts
and place it on our target substrate we
then heat this
to 120c to remove the thermal release
tape that's why it's called thermal
release tape
then we chemically etch away the gold
leaving the cnts on the wafer substrate
next we coat this layer of cnts with a
very thin layer of polymer
about five nanometers thin now this
polymer layer is absolutely essential
so keep this in the back of your mind
next
we are free to do as many repeated
transfers as you want
so for a second transfer we get our
second growth wafer
we re-coat it with another layer of gold
and thermal release tape
we transfer this on top of the target
wafer we remove the thermal release tape
in gold
we coat it with another thin layer of
polymer and we just keep repeating the
process
for as many times as you want are there
any alignment issues
uh that's a good question so right now
how we do the transfers
is uh well by me uh so it's me sitting
in the hand doing this
optically aligning now it turns out your
eyes are actually
exceptionally accurate to a rotational
alignment
uh like micro radiant it's remarkable i
think that's the number
um but this can easily be done by a
machine
which can you know simply take pick it
up move it over and put it down
uh so uh and also that being said what a
lineman ends up contributing to his
variations
and it turns out the alignment doesn't
affect as long as a reasonable amount
uh certainly even just what i can do by
eye doesn't end up affecting the
circuits
so what goes wrong in the third one you
said you can only do it up to three
times
oh so four is this absolutely bad so i'm
sorry
you said before you cannot do it more
than three well so if you're doing the
heat transfer just sticking it on the
wafer just keep doing it over and over
again
you can only do three times i'll show
you that with this process
we can do an arbitrary number and here
i'll show you right here actually
13 times so we start with what we can
grow eight cnts per micron
uh that's for one transfer and then we
do 13 transfers
and we can achieve over a hundred cds
per micron isolating them
exactly right and what i want to show
you there i glossed over a little bit of
the process
but a really key part of that is that
polymer layer because it essentially
acts as an epoxy for the transfer to
adhere to
i the adhesion energy of the transfer to
the substrate which is how well it
adheres to the substrate
i greatly increases with a polymer on
there with no
versus just a blank oxide substrate by
over 600 percent
and what i want to highlight for you is
that in the back of your mind you might
be thinking well this
sounds like pretty sketchy it's like a
little scotch tape based transfer method
right how could this ever be
manufacturable
what i want to show you is we can look
at since we don't think in terms of
adhesion energy units joules per meter
squared
but there are other processing steps uh
for instance the adhesion
between a locate dielectric to a copper
metal wire for a cmp damaging process
and there's an adhesion threshold for
that dielectric on the metal wire
and the cider adhesion energy actually
exceeds that
which really shows that this is not some
sketchy process
but rather a manufacturable way for
scale robust process
and that is a very important takeaway
message
okay and again you know these aren't
just pictures of pretty aligned cnt we
can actually calculate the idc across
these transfers
and show that the idc maintains a
starting growth idc
of around a half all right but what we
really care about
are not just pretty pictures but
electrical performance
so you can see this is for a set of 50
cn fets a channel length of 400
nanometers supply voltage of one volt
uh you see that we can achieve very high
drive currents around 350 micrograms per
micron on average
with drive currents approaching 600
microamps per micron
now if i just showed you this you'd say
hey well that looks good
but your on off ratio is two you know
there's massive leakage current this is
not going to build a high performance
circuit
all right it won't even build out
probably any circuit actually uh
and you're completely correct but what i
want to show you is we know how to deal
with this problem
this is due to metallic cnts so we use
vmr
to remove the metallic cnts and now for
those same set of 50c in fats
we can achieve very high on off ratios
an average of over 5000
but now you might ask me well the
current has decreased right
so i'll show you this explicitly for the
same c in fact before and after
breakdown
you see the current does indeed decrease
but
this is expected because we have
intentionally removed
the metallic c and t's from the c and
fat and in fact
if we take into account that a metallic
c and t doesn't have a band gap of
you know exactly zero it's on off ratio
isn't exactly one
it's we measure let's say 1.4 we can
actually calculate
that we're retaining after breakdown
over 90 percent of the maximum possible
current
that could be achieved really showing
that both cider
and vmr are not degrading the
performance of our cn fats
so now that we have these seemingly high
performance c and fats
the question is well how high
performance are they and to determine
this we can benchmark them
against silicon transistors using
commercial foundry pdk models of silicon
transistors in production
so to do this we take the foundry pdk
model
and we begin by normalizing the device
geometry so we set them
to the same geometry as rc and that's
the channeling to 400 nanometers with
one micron
we then i set the biasing conditions the
same so one volt supply voltage
and importantly we set the vt to achieve
this
to achieve the same off current as our c
in fats so this drive current is
benchmarked for the same off current
obviously
which is important and then we extract
the drive current given the same maximum
gate field
to normalize for differences in eot or
oxide thickness
and essentially at the end of the day we
see that our best sean fetts
can achieve between 82 to 94 percent of
the drive current
of silicon-based transistors by showing
that really for the first time
our cn fets are now competitive with
silicon-based technologies
so now that we're talking about really
achieving performance
uh for systems we cannot ignore
variations yeah
backing up that was 28 nanometers for
the
yes this is a 20 nanometer node pdk with
the transistor
normalized to our device the trend is
down
what what is the 14s and the 22. yeah
that's that's a really good question so
wait you're saying the
the traffic light from the 350 and 28 is
down yeah so
when so the key reason why that trend
exists is because
these are all normalized to a 400
nanometer channel length
and device scaling doesn't perfectly
match whatever else
okay but we can it's a very interesting
uh kind of divisive stuff there so we
can talk offline about that
it's pretty interesting but you know the
point is that you know the point of this
benchmark is not to say 82 to 94
right the point of this is to say it's
it's getting there right yeah
but we can
when you say getting there any any
reason why
it is not better certainly um
and you know i'll talk about this after
about no future work but uh
there are still certainly obstacles to
achieve or to overcome for sea and fence
right a big one for instance would be
contact resistance
um this is a major obstacle for not just
cmts
but a whole class of one 2d
nanomaterials i know by the way not just
these emerging noun technologies but
when you scale down
it's also a problem for even silicon for
any technology when you scale
so there are certainly obstacles that
still need to be overcome
but i really want to emphasize that i
it's exciting to have an emerging
technology which can actually you know
benchmark against silicon
you know isn't 100x off for something
right this is for the same off curve
right
this is technology benchmarking showing
that it's getting as comfortable
okay but right that's for transistors if
you want to build systems
we really have to be worried about
variations and this is where
you know there are many sources of
variations for a circuit i already spoke
about density variations
but you know there we've all heard
perhaps of diameter variations between
carbon nanotubes
uh and then we also have traditional
variations oxides thickness variation
channel length variations that are even
in silicon cmos
and the question is what variations do
we have to worry the most about
now if you look at a single transistor
with a single carbon nanotube
you'll reach the wrong conclusion you'll
see that diameter variations are the
most important
but in a real system your minimum size c
in fact does not have a single carbon
nanotube
you need to have sufficient drive
current so your minimum size c and fat
has between let's say six to ten carbon
nanotubes
and this creates an averaging effect
then it turns out that diameter
variations actually contribute a very
small amount to variations that affect
you at the system level
which is what we ultimately care about
the variations that dominate
are we call cnt count variations which
are variations in the number of c and
t's
uh per unit width essentially and there
are two
sources of c t count variations uh the
first is grown c d density variations
that i spoke to
and the second is m c and t induced
so let me take these each one by one i
just want to remind you quickly about
you know idc and the non-uniform spacing
contributing
to account variation and we characterize
this with that metric idc
but then there's the another source on
top of this which also contributes to ct
count variations
which is the probabilistic presence and
removal of the metallic carbon nanotubes
and this is where i'm starting to
address a previous question i got
about that four percent removing the
semi-conductance and t's
um so i'll define the probability of c
and t is grown metallic as p
sub m and then the probability uh semi
a c and t is semiconducting is one minus
pm
and oh by the way we've shown
experimentally that these are iid
so a cnt is semi-conducting or metallic
is independent of its neighbor
so if we take an experimentally
achievable pm of one percent
and a trivial case of a transistor with
three c and t's
we can calculate that 97 of the time we
will have three semiconducting c and t's
but three percent of the time about will
only have two semiconducting c and t's
because one will be metallic
and 0.001 percent of the time they'll
all be metallic which is a
non-traditional percentage again
for vlsi scale circuits so you see how
just the probabilistic presence of
metallic c and t's
contribute to count variations now
on top of that we also have a
probabilistic removal of the metallic
carbon nanotubes
i'll define the probability of c and t
is removed given it is metallic
as p r sub m and the probability of c
and t is removed given it is
semiconducting
as p r sub s now we know from vmr
what these numbers are experimentally pr
sub m is 99.99
pr sub s is four percent so we can
calculate that given that case of having
two semiconducting and one metallic
carbon nanotubes
uh ninety percent of the time it's the
best case we only remove the metallic c
and t's
but hey you know 0.2 percent of the time
we remove everything
so you have device failure so you see
how both the probabilistic presence and
removal of the metallic carbon nanotubes
contribute to count variations
okay so what's the solution well one
solution is obviously don't do nothing
or don't do anything um but then we
don't have a technology
so this is a sub-optimal solution it's
very safe
uh there's another solution which is to
upsize everything
this will average out variations and
your circuits will work
but it comes at a huge energy cost so it
defeats the purpose of using c infects
in the first place
so i'll show you that we can actually
engineer specific cnt correlations
into our circuit which can give us big
benefits
and the trick here is to remember that c
and t's are one-dimensional
nanostructures
in this slide there are these vertical
wires running on the side here
so if i build two c and side by side
they're composed of different c and t's
and thus are uncorrelated but if i put
these two transistors on top of one
another
i see that they are composed of
essentially identical carbon nanotubes
and thus are highly correlated so you
see how through placement you can
engineer correlation and uncorrelation
into your circuits
and we can use this to our advantage
with the line active layouts
let me give you yeah so no tube is both
you never have the case where a single
tube is both conducting and
semi-conducting metallic that's a good
question yeah so it's been
experimentally shown
uh by bone effects along the length that
a cnt maintains chirality
now if it does if it didn't right then
that would simply affect you still have
correlation just wouldn't be 100
right so the same concept still applied
and for instance this is actually if you
notice in this
sem here there's one cnt which doesn't
go all the way through yeah
right and why do we use this is it
because we can't find an scm where
they're perfect
of course not it's hard to find this
actually it doesn't happen often
is to just make that point that and
i say that correlation is not perfect
right they're just highly correlated
which is key right you can take that
into your design right how much
correlation you have
if you have a kink i thought you could
change it from italic to number
one source oh okay so you're so
straight yeah so it depends how the
questions phrase and
i think getting really into this the
jury's still out there
i've seen kind of a few conflicting
things on this it's a very difficult
experiment to perform
um but again it's a very small
percentage
so it just affects how much correlation
you can count on when you design your
circuit so it's just another design
thing that you put inside your
design framework so it's not a
fundamental obstacle if it does for
instance
so worst case even without a pink it
still changes
but we know happens very infrequently so
the correlation is still there
so how do we use this correlation well i
think you can kind of see how it's
through aligned active layouts
so let's say we have a circuit with 1 2
and so on and so forth c in facts
the probability that the circuit works
is the probability that the first c in
fact
doesn't fail and the probability of the
second c effect doesn't fail and the
probability the certainty in fact
doesn't fail et cetera
now if these are all uncorrelated c in
facts and completely independent
these ends are multiplied and the bigger
my circuit becomes
the probability that the circuit works
exponentially drops but
you see that they're all aligned right
so now all of these transistors
the probability that one works will be
approximately equal to the probability
that any of the c in fats work so these
adds become approximately equals
and no matter how big the circuit
becomes the probability of the circuit
working will stay
at the probability of a single
transistor working this can give us big
benefits
this is an example of how you can
engineer correlations into your circuit
to reach a better design point but now
you want to do even better and if you
want to do better
you need to start improving the
processing parameters so how does this
work
well you have a scientist in the lab
who's working on
you know the science stuff right this is
what i do typically it's looking at
you know improving these parameters i've
been talking about idc this is the
spacing variations right or
pm or pure growth et cetera you also
have a designer
who's working on these vmr structures
and these align active layouts i showed
you
and their task is combined they somehow
need to reach the best design point for
their
circuit which means they have the best
noise margins uh the best delay
variation the best yield etc and the
question is well how do they do this
because the design space is huge so we
start here
this is with our variations we have
today all these numbers i've been
talking about not ec of a half
you know pm of 99. of one percent of prs
as
four percent let's say and every edge on
this graph
is a different processing parameter i
can tweak
and without knowing what parameters
should i tweak it's
we don't know which line to go down so
for a large
time you know a large amount of time
it's been less focused on
improving the purity of our growth
improving pm so if we can go from 10
to 5 we can get big benefits but if you
just focus on improving one parameter
you quickly reach a regime of
diminishing returns so just focusing on
one parameter
is very inefficient so we can in sense
instead say well let's actually stop at
five percent because that gives us big
benefits
and now let's improve idc the spacing
variations just slightly from 0.5 to
0.25
now will improve pr sub s of 5 to 2.5
percent
and you see how i combine by how
improving each parameter just slightly
you can reach a much better design point
than by just focusing on one parameter
this again really emphasizes the
importance of being able to look at how
variations at the device scale
affect you all the way up at the system
level what do they go back to chirality
sorry blue yellow and then another blue
yeah no so um i
there are what i'll say about this and
this is a very important point is that
you know why you're you know going down
this optimization right what
what do you want to do right there you
can always tweak things additionally
right
and this is why it's important to be
able to explore this big design space
uh so i if you're doing the same monte
carlo it's
very time consuming right so there are
other students in our group
uh so gage hills has one of these
students who has a dac paper
i think last year the year before which
really looks at
basically looking at this as a grading
descent problem so you look
at what parameters should i tweak at as
i go along here
to reach the best design point and
the importance of being able to look at
this design space quickly is that
well here i give you one path which
works so this is a pm of five percent
idc of a half
and pr is the best of 2.5 but
what if you know my scientist says okay
i can do this i can do this but this
no way what do you do well you need to
find another path
so it's very important being able to
examine multiple paths
so that you can really guide uh the
science side of the understanding and
recycle those paths if you go the blue
down
saturates add the yellow saturates now
if you try again the blue to continue
that may not saturate the same way yeah
so i
they're additives so you know at the end
of the day when you look at your design
you have some pm some idc some pr sms
so if you optimize pm and idc then pm
again then it's just you know you're
it's looking at the same design point of
an idc of you know of some value and pm
of some value
um but in the optimization process
you're not guaranteed you know that's
where you might
look at different paths and go back and
forth
okay um so
i think the future of this technology is
looking
promising at least you know this 10x
benefit is looking more and more
feasible
but i want to pose a question well how
do we do even better
what if we want to get to 1000x so if we
want to really do better
we need to start combining the benefits
we can achieve at the device scale
with benefits we can achieve at the
architectural and system scale
and to that end 3d integration is a very
promising path
now 3d integration today is
traditionally achieved
through chip stacking which is when we
build the different wafers on separate
substrates
and then stack them one on top of each
other
and bond together you then connect the
different vertical layers with our
through silicon vias or tsvs
which can be rather large now what i'll
be talking about
is monolithic 3d integration you know
the dream of 3d
which is when we can fabricate each of
these different vertical layers
directly on top of one another all in
the same substrate
this allows you to use conventional
nanoscale interlayer vias or ilvs to
connect different vertical layers of the
circuit
which can be orders of magnitude
thousand x denser
than the larger ts feeds and this allows
us to have a massive increase in
connectivity between the vertical layers
and where we can really leverage that is
when we use monolithic 3d to stack
layers of logic
and memory on top of one another because
now this massive increase in
connectivity between the vertical layers
directly translates to a large increase
in our logic to memory bandwidth which
can have significant positive impacts
on our system level performance both in
terms of energy and performance
i'll give you just three examples how so
of course this is not an exhaustive life
right so first off the memory access
time
is reduced so your processor doesn't
have to be idle for as many cycles
waiting to get memory or waiting to get
the data from the memory
additionally the memory access energy is
reduced because the logic and memory are
stacked directly on top of one another
and the research contention is also
reduced due to this wide connectivity
between the vertical layers now
despite the promise of monolithic 3d
there's always a catch
right and the catch here is that it's
part of build
the processing temperature for all these
top layers
has to be very low below 400 c anything
above this
and we damage the bottom layer circuits
and the low temperature metal
interconnects
and it's particularly a problem for a
traditional silicon cmos
which has traditionally very high
processing for steps such as dope
activation and kneeling
you're talking at temperatures above 900
1000 degrees c
well above this thermal budget
so we can really leverage these new
immersion nanotechnologies
to enable monolithic 3d integration
because these emerging nanotechnologies
as i'll show you can be fabricated at
very low
processing temperatures below 200 c well
within our thermal budget
for logic i'll show you we can use c in
facts
obviously as i've been talking about a
very promising technology for
digital logic and for memory there's a
whole host of emerging memories we can
choose from
rrm st ram cbram you really choose
what's best
for your application today i'll show you
examples using rm
and what i really want to highlight
about this approach is that we can
really now combine the benefits at the
device scale
and the architectural scale because not
only do these new devices
enable this architecture which gives us
a lot of benefits but we now also
get to get the benefits of using these
new devices these energy efficient high
performance devices
so how do we build these 3d ics these
monolithic 3d ics
well we start with our blank silicon
substrate we begin just as you normally
would
building the bottom layer of logic so i
do this here in our lab it's a layer of
silicon cmos
and i want to make two very important
points here
the first is that the processing
temperature for the silicon
is very high as i mentioned our dopant
activation kneeling is 1050c
so the silicon can only be on this
bottom layer
not anywhere else in this 3d stack now
the second point i want to make
is why do we do this on silicon is it
because we have to no
this could be a layer of very high
performance c in fat logic
we choose to do this on top of silicon
cmos to demonstrate
that not only is everything you've seen
today way for scale and vlsi scale
compatible
but also silicon cmos compatible which
is a very important point
because you know no matter how promising
your technology becomes
we have to realize that you know silicon
cmos is at least in the foreseeable
future an indispensable technology
so being compatible with silicon both in
terms of design and processing
is uh very important for lowering that
uh
threshold of entry so once we build that
bottom layer
we then need to build or get ready to
build the second layer on top
so we first deposit inner layer
dielectric and passivation layer
and ild with a low temperature pcb oxide
followed by etching and filling are
metal vias i want to re-emphasize
that these can be our you know
conventional nanoscale ilvs
very very dense because this is
monolithic 3d integration
now that i have my ild and ilvs i can
then build the second layer of the 3d ic
directly on top
and we choose this to be memory on a
layer of ram
so we put down the first layer of metal
for the ram the metal oxide in between
followed by the top layer metal forming
the ram sandwich
so now we have our second layer of
memory we repeat that same step between
every layer
another layer of ilds and ilvs and then
we can build a third layer
again we choose this to be memory so we
do another layer of rrm
again we do ilds and ilvs and then we do
our fourth layer
and we choose this to be logic again
using c and effects
and i've drawn the c in facts here uh
the process is just a single step
but you know that we have to do
everything you've seen before so far
right
so we have to use a misposition cnt
immune design vmr
to overcome those obstacles um and
importantly
also that transfer process cider because
what that transfer really does
is it decouples the high temperature cnt
growth
from the wafer where we build our
circuits on the cnts grow at 900 c
around there
too hot to grow directly on our chip but
the transfer is very low temperature
120c
so the wafer we build our circuits on
never goes above that temperature
so this allows us to build
monolithically 3d ics using c effects
and i want to highlight that just as i
showed you before
the transfer does not affect the cnts
even for 3d transfers
maintaining both the density and
alignment of the carbon nanotubes
now these are not just pretty pictures i
want to show you we've actually
built such monolithically integrated 3d
ics in our lab
so here's a cross-section tem of the
bottom layer of silicon transistors
you can see the crystalline silicon in
the channel the amorphous
high-key gate dielectric on top followed
by the gate metal on top of that
on top of the silicon transistors we
have two layers of rram
here's again the cross section tm of the
2rm if we zoom in on the rm
we can see again the metal stack of the
rm sandwiched in between
two of those ilds and directly on top of
the rm
we build the c effect here you see the
cross-section tem of the c
in fat through the source if we zoom in
you can see roughly the open mouth of a
cnt
sandwiched in between the metal on top
the source metal and the dielectric
underneath
so this forms with the four layers of
this 3d ic
but of course we don't just care about
building single devices on top of each
other right
this whole presentation is on realizing
nanosystems
so we want to show we can actually build
a system out of this so we can build for
instance a
basic two by two crossbar which
essentially programmably connects two
different inputs to two different
outputs
through programmable routing elements
now
each rounding element is implemented as
follows we use
rrm based configuration memory which is
programmed by the c and phat
so the c in phet programs let's say one
rrm into a low resistance state
then the other ram into a high
resistance state and then when we apply
a voltage across these two bit lines
the resistance divider of the rrm sets a
voltage at the gate node of the silicon
transistor
turning it turning it on or off so the
silicon transistor acts as a pass gate
between the input and output here's the
sem of that
fabricated 2x2 crossbar this is a top
down
sem view and each one of these make up
each one of those routing elements and
here's a zoom out
of one of those routing elements on the
bottom layer
we have our silicon transistors directly
on top
we build the first layer of rrm directly
on top of that
we build the next layer of rrm and
directly on top of that we build the c
and fast fact
so each of these layers is silicon fats
rm rmc and fets are built directly on
top
overlapping one another
uh here's the results showing you the
crossbar actually works
so we begin by programming the crossbar
to connect m1 to out one
and in two to out two we measure the
currents between the inputs and outputs
see that's indeed the case
and then we can reprogram the same
crossbar and connect m1 to out two
and in two to out one and again see a
correct functional operation
so now that we can actually build
systems using this integration scheme
i think this really opens the door to
enabling some very exciting
abundant data applications because in my
mind when you when you think about what
you need
for these new applications we can break
it down into three parts
the first is we need to create this
abundant data or this big data right the
creation of the data
which involves sensors and for some
applications we might want
millions of sensors and it's very
difficult to package those all to fit
inside of a cell phone
and on top of that if you need to upload
this all into the cloud you have a data
deluge
so building it on a chip is on chip is a
great way to overcome this
now once we create the data we then need
to move it around the chip
so this is the communication of the data
and this is where we can really leverage
these new architectures using monolithic
3d
and these very dense inner layer via is
connecting the different layers
from the sensors down to the chip and
then in between the layers of logic and
memory
and then once we can actually move the
data around we then need to compute
on this massive amount of data and this
is where these
very energy efficient 1d 2d
nanomaterials come into play
for building energy efficient
transistors and memory
and what i really want to emphasize here
is that
all aspects of this whether it's the
sensors or the 3d integration or the
energy
efficient devices are really inherently
naturally
enabled and well suited by using these
new 1v2
nanomaterials and they make great
sensors i showed you it can enable
very energy efficient devices and
architectures i think it's a very
promising path forward
now that being said there are still
obstacles to be overcome uh
on the device scale uh especially when
we scale down contact resistance will be
a major issue as i spoke about
but not just for emerging technologies
also for silicon
the dielectric interactions between the
oxide and these new materials have to be
studied
they're also they're very interesting
questions at the system level
you know such as how does our system
design change what sort of memory
hierarchies do we want to use
and what about the power dissipation of
these layers directly on top of each
other
and what about yield across these
different layers and they're also very
interesting questions when we talk about
applications
so now that you can build such a chip
how do you really want to leverage
all this data to do something very
useful and what i think is even more
interesting
is based on the application how does
then that
impact your system and device level
requirements really making this a
closed-loop optimization process
and i guess i'll i'll summarize and end
by saying that while i think
nano systems certainly have obstacles
moving forwards
i more i'd like to view this as seen as
nano systems
have many opportunities moving forwards
so in summaries all right in summary i
i hope i've been able to show that we
can now build systems using cnfetz
whether through sasha or through that
basic computer and that these systems
can really have some more and more
applications
such as that integrated sensor sensor
interface circuit
uh and it's not just we can build
systems but we can now try and get
performance as well
with these high performance c and fats
that can now compete with silicon
and scaling down into highly scaled
channel lengths
and beyond this we can really use these
technologies to enable brand new
architectures
such as monolithically integrated 3d ics
with interleaving layers of logic and
memory
which are very promising for these big
data applications
uh so with that i'd like to acknowledge
all of our collaborators and
all of our sponsors for their support
i'd like to acknowledge you for your uh
kind of tension and your interactions i
really enjoy that
and i i guess i wait you said this is
like a defense that people ask tough
questions now right
so yeah i think i'll wrap up and thank
you appreciate it
what would you say the current the
biggest challenges are right now
and using this technology to making
a competitive processor to the current
commercial arm processors
that's a really good question so for
anyone who didn't hear it i'm sure you
could have but uh
it's basically what are the big
obstacles towards realizing
uh processor that compete with silicon
right yeah
r and processor otherwise right yeah and
so i think there are
several different ways to approach that
from the device scale
i think certainly the biggest obstacles
will be contact resistance
and then a second very important
obstacle would be control doping
to get complementary logic especially
using cnts and these new materials
because the dopings can be very
challenging
but what i want to say about that are
two things
so first most people think that you
can't do cmos
using cnts that they're only p-type not
in type let's say
and that's probably the single biggest
misnomer in
cnt land it's not true that they're
inherently p-type and
intrinsic cnt is intrinsic right it
depends on what metal contacts you use
for to form the shocky barrier to
whether it's p or n type
and we know that we can build n n p type
c in facts
there's some very interesting ways that
you can actually do cmos
using these very thin nanomaterials such
as with electrostatically doping
so based on the oxide interfaces on top
of the cnts they have charges in that
interface
which can electrostatically dope the
surface of a material
and when you're talking about the cnt
that's the material right
so they're very so we know i think we
know very well how we want to do doping
we can do doping the question now is how
to control it
to have controllable doping and
controllable threshold voltages
so that's from the device aspect but
then i think
i we have to be smart about how we want
to
uh start using cnts and what
applications we want to use it in you
know do you want to start by just
building the exact same processor
using cnts instead of silicon or do you
instead want to possibly
solve base exactly do you want to
instead maybe a great way for
integration is this monolithic 3d
where you start with your silicon
substrate then maybe you build your
layer of very high performance
uh low power c sensor interfaces which
are also sensors for instance
which have logic in there right which
can be at a lag node even
right or you know so i think they're
very interesting discussions to be had
about
the best way to start actually taking
this technology
to the next level uh and that being said
uh
it is getting industry protection
attention there's great work done on
cnts from ibm for instance
uh so uh i think i you know no one has a
crystal ball looking in the future
but i hope that the future is at least
uh promising
let's start here and then over there um
what density did you achieve for the
intra-layered vs oh yeah okay so the
question is what density can achieve
with ilvs
so in our lab uh so of course you know
so a lot of these demonstrations are not
done at
16 nanometer node right because
everything i showed you from beginning
the growth of the cnts to the final chip
tape out if you want to call it that to
measurement is all done at stanford
and our lab is of course not up to spec
to
intel fab or industry fab right so our
minimum feature
is around 500 nanometers so when we do
these monolithic 3d integrations
as an idea we can pretty easily achieve
let's say a pitch of a micron
now even that pitch is much much better
than what typical tsv
pitch is even in industry right there
you're looking typically
when you're when you're looking at
things let's say 40 or 50 microns in
pitch
um so we're not you know we're limited
by
you know our limitations here in fab you
know if you look at kind of rit rs
projections of what or just look at what
your pitch is for m6 or global metal
wires
you're looking at a density increase of
more than a thousand
of ilvs versus tsvs and that's not
extrapolating to some crazy technology
that's just looking at the pitch of
tsv's
versus the global wire pitch
resistive devices are basically
oxides between two layer methods right
so my question is
why did you use the science v
and the different layers in the modern
monolithic 3d and not just
dedicated to metal layers on top of the
okay so so the question was that rrm is
very simple to build as metal locks and
metal
so why not just do that in the metal
stack right why why are you talking
about monolithic 3d
well you know you can do that and people
do are on top of logic
but you don't do logic on top of memory
on top of logic right
i so being able to really densely
integrate
logic and memory on top of each other
really have computation immersed in
memory
is i think a very promising path
forwards and certainly if you want
you know if you instead go from dm off
chip just to rm on top of your chip
let's say right
uh for main memory that gives you big
benefits right i think you can get even
more benefits
when you can really really densely
integrate these technologies
so not just having logic just on one
layer but you can have your memory
controllers for instance
on in logic on top of it for instance
right so it doesn't need to take up
real estate on that bottom layer so you
can do tricks like that so you can put
your memory controller just as an
example right
on top of the memory on a separate layer
from where your computation is and your
memory
so that's a great example
can you do optical processing with cnt
that's a good question so can you do
optical processing with cnts
you know i don't want to say yes or no
because i don't want to say anything
incorrect that's going to go out on
youtube
all right so what i will say
is that you turn out font of truth
no i don't i don't want to tag you down
and say hey you said this like where's
the truth and then i need to spend 10
years trying to make it work right
can you prove myself right if you say no
then it doesn't work exactly
yes i need to be very careful so so what
i'll say is that i have seen
you know conferences especially some
very nice work
of using optical properties of cnts both
to
emit light uh and to measure it so if
you're looking at
uh whether you're doing computation for
instance or if you're even
not also even computation with life but
even if you're looking at uh
communicating right so like on chip like
communication for instance right
i think there are possibilities there um
but i don't want to say whether or not
you know how promising i think that is
or how feasible it is in the future
there's good work there's been some work
on harvard on that ucla on this
uh but that's kind of where i'll leave
that
what about the thermal properties to get
rid of the heat on the center of one of
these 3d stacks
okay yeah that's a great question it has
to do what about the thermal aspects of
building 3d chips
because if you're stacking logic on
logic or let's say memory on logical
memory
you're stacking layers on top of each
other so it's more challenging to get
the heat out because that
logic layer isn't on a heatsink for
instance
the cnts are great for me all right
exactly yeah so there are
great ways to approach this problem
again both through fabrication and
device device
approaches and through design approaches
uh
so from a design perspective uh there's
some work from a previous student in our
group
who looked at using the power distrib
power distribution networks
as a method of distributing the heat
across a layer for instance
and then from a more device side there
is interesting work here
done for instance by a professor pop
eric pop
who's looking at using nano meshes new
nano materials
in between layers to help spread out
heat as well so there are definitely
and as you mentioned cnts themselves are
great uh thermal conductors
so there are definitely approaches but
this is an area which needs to be looked
into
and what i'll say there is having be
able to show that technology is
actually feasible actually showing hey
we can actually build these circuits
really then helps
you know uh the motivation to then look
into these problems so we're seeing more
and more work
looking at how do we deal with these
hotspot issues for monolithic 3d
specifically
so now that you can show what technology
is more feasible you know there's more
and more work it's kind of a rolling
ball
snowball effect which is exciting well
the other thing that gets rid of people
fast and some of those things is diamond
yeah so yeah new materials right like uh
and if you put diamond process
i'm not an expert using uh and diamond
there are people who
do right so i i don't know about cost or
anything but i
what we'll see just as cheap yeah
we'll see right again i don't want to
say yes or no so we'll see
catching your beds been there ten years
ago
they could get really heat so fast that
you patent it and then the us government
steals it
off why didn't you do that 20 years ago
so we've done logic memory memory logic
and is there any reason why we didn't do
10 layers honestly no right it's because
the conference deadline came up and we
wanted to show something and we had
built four layers
um
really when you look at what are the
obstacles to building more layers
i it's not you know i'm not hiding
something from you there it really is
that if we wanted to build five or six
or ten layers we could do that for you
and an interesting question is well how
many layers do you actually want
for your chip what's the best design
here do you want
a thousand layers or are you okay with
building five layers
of obviously the metal layers inside
there as well right
so that's an interesting question
looking forward and how do you actually
want to optimize the system design
how does adding more layers influence
the overall yield
means the total number of devices the
relevant
measure well yes or no so if you look at
let's say you have a million transistors
just on your chip or a billion let's say
right
and let's say you have five layers of
those billion transistors
then you need all five layers to work
versus if you just have a billing
transition in your circuit
then it's easier to make work right so
you have more circuits when you're doing
monolithic 3d you can't have at least
right so you can have the same footprint
area the same device on one layer
but you can now have you have more real
estate so you can build more transistors
uh so there's that issue is not to be
clear about something it's not that the
monolithic 3d process
itself is hurting yield so we've shown
that the 3d process
doesn't affect the layers below it and
that's because of the low thermal
processing
so that's an important point when
talking about yield is because we have
more devices across more layers it's not
because a 3d process is damaging the
bottom layers
so if you build a thousand the
probability of damaging the bottom layer
increases
so it's not that so the interconnect is
reasonably reliable
oh so yes yes this is you know this
doesn't involve wafer bonding
or tsv's or where you can have cracks or
something this is a
really just regular fabrication you go
up to your global wire
layer and then you can build your next
layer of logic or something directly on
top of that
so the processing really doesn't change
between these layers and
they're no significant um alignment
issues going up the stack oh
that that's that's another really key
point because we're not doing bonding
you know the biggest i don't say the
biggest because i don't talk in
absolutes right
but a very big source of misalignment in
your process
is not you know your overlay accuracy
for lithography on the same layer is
very good right
a big source of misalignment comes in
actual bonding yeah
right so that's where you have probably
one of the biggest sources of
misalignment
so this doesn't have bonding you're
building on the same exact layer all the
way up using the same alignment marks
layer on top of layer
so your overlay accuracy stays the same
um but
you know the reason for that large tsv
pitch is both due to the bonding and
accuracy but also due to keep out zones
of tsps for instance because of stress
keep out zones is what it's called
around a tsv because they're stress
induced
right yes yes so that pitch is both due
to
you know misalignment but also through
the keep out zones
um but in terms of the misalignment and
accuracy the reason
why we can use these very dense ilvs
is because the overlay accuracy is using
the same alignment same substrate
and there's no problem if it's drifts to
the top of the stack to the bottom of
the stack it just
cleaning tower of paint set yeah i don't
wanna again i don't say yes or no to
that
you know you know i don't know if you
have a case of having a wire going all
the way down but
i see that case as well right so i think
they're very interesting
and this certainly gets into the space
of more of a you know industry designer
when they look at something like drift
across too many layers right
um but yeah i think there there are
going to be interesting ways to approach
that issue
yeah i want to dominate this what are
the trade-offs between the different
using
these new different kinds of these new
rams do you want to use rram or one of
the other guys or
that's a good question so it so i'll say
that all these new memories
are looking very exciting so if you just
if you browse through the proceedings of
the
your most recent idm right you see
real significant size chips using you
know rn or sdt or whatnot
so you know these are very promising
memory technologies
and which have different uh
characteristics they have different
write speeds different read speeds
different
latencies different you know energies
associated with them
so i think you know one possible
configuration just to give you an
example
but you can still use sram for l1 and
for l2
uh you can use stt and then for your
main memory you can use something like
ram
uh because you also have to take into
account uh
um especially for these new memories how
many times you can write to them yes
right and this is where you can it also
depends on your application right
so uh it becomes very uh becomes
interesting
so i think yeah but i think that that
route for instance ram for massive
uh because it's very simple it's very
dense for a main memory on chip is a
promising route
can this be the last question sure we
can stick around
after and ask questions sorry yeah we
could usually close down the gay hammer
and then it can tell us
the truth that's the plan
yeah less thought uh
something that uh i've always liked and
never had enough of was content
addressable memory
and content addressable memory is much
easier implemented in 3d than
2d in any case i don't know how big you
could make it in
3d but you just can't get enough of it
yeah i think uh memory hierarchies are
something which definitely be explored
and exploited
you